[Musique]
salut ça me suivre bon aujourd'hui c'est
le jour j
le jour du lancement de la présentation
du show me mit l'on a plutôt cool
donc bon commencez par vos placards
escrime de vêtements un quoi il est déjà
là bas je vous explique
[Musique]
salut c'est monsieur
alors aujourd'hui après une nuit très
très courte beaucoup trop courte suis
complètement fatigué regardez moi cette
tronche de c'est juste pas possible
aujourd'hui on va lancement global de
chez home y rencontrer les nouveaux
smartphones bâtiment qu'on en parle déjà
mis deux amis de a light des smartphones
qui devraient être franchement cool donc
qu'on va faire c'est qu'on m'a décembre
prendre un p'tit déj parce qu'il faut
quand même prendre des forces
trente minutes on va là la conférence on
va voir ce que ça dit on va dans la zone
d'expérience pour prendre les produits
en mains je vais vous donner mon avis
sur une première prise en main et puis
rassurez vous on en reparlera très
prochainement on y va
[Musique]
alors là on est devant le camp mais sa
pelle within this week
le week le wing thundering center le
wheezing center on va y avoir la
confiance d'ailleurs on rentre je pense
qu'il faudrait des risques on va se
retrouver comme des couleurs ouais on
alla donc la présentation de deux chiots
me d'ici quelques instants
bon c'est pas arrivé complètement à la
bourre donc voilà donc c'est plutôt
plutôt cool et au fond vous avez un
espèce de cailloux sais pas si ça se
voit une création et de dolmen géant
qu'un caillou dessus là il fallait oser
pour rabat salé que toujours faire la
queue pour le récupérer quand les bonnes
allez on y va le monde alors qu'il
fouille au corps au bio corde pour
commencer déjà fou chantant et
traditionnelles matin ça fait du bien et
toi tu filmes avec avec un succès fou
j'essaie de régulateur ouais au top
comportement qui ça va cool à aller
boire un coup ok donc le nouveau là avec
un badge médias hélas quand même pas se
mentir c'est la grande classe
alors vous voyez près toujours chaud
patate à android one on est toujours
prêts à sézanne a dit ce qu'on
représente la maison c'est ça absolument
c'est absolument la belle maison
la belle maison jaune on a les mains de
charlieu france
non non moi je représente frandroid et
vraiment je sais fendri en fin d'année
évidemment là mêmes lunettes tant marqué
ou parfois sur les blues brothers
le grondement du
[Musique]
m
oui champagne allez ça c'est quand mes
gonds et inez leca leur job 15
10h15 tout va bien sorti à la bonne tu
sais quoi tu dois venir boire un coup
avec nous parce que j'arrive te rejoins
il n'a rien reçu ces petites limonade du
matin sympathique
on a aussi un petit cocktail de chips ça
c'est un truc de ouf on est à quelques
minutes du lancement de l'événement et
vous avez dans le centre de conférence
plein de photos
la dalle affiche qui vous donne des
infos dessus là par exemple vous avez
mis à dos light dual camera deux jours
de batterie qu'est-ce qu'on a encore
comme info alors on a effectivement
voilà ça ça doit être le demi à deux
vous avez des infos ici voilà une jolie
petite encoche placardé la la caméra ici
double capteur photo bien évidemment et
ça on le savait déjà
android one mis à deux caméras 20
mégapixels
voilà donc là on a toute une galerie
avec des images des smartphones qui se
dévoile déjà avant même la présentation
officielle donc ça bros pourquoi pas
voilà donc là on est encore là et on
retourne de l'autre côté ici sur le mit
à 2,6 me advate me advate voilà donc ça
c'est plutôt cool
alors comme ça ça m'a permis de vous le
partagez déjà sur twitter puis dans un
très bon point maintenant on va les voir
directement dans le centre de conférence
on attend la présentation voir ce que
vont donner c'est me à 2 me et de light
on va les prendre en main une zone
d'expérience pour le tester après donc
ça c'est plutôt cool
[Musique]
bon par contre qu'il faudrait mettre à
jour un petit peu les affiches aux
portes sont ouvertes forcément film dans
le noir qu'on se voit pas en bas que ça
se passe comme une personne ici on
traduit minimum
400 500 se remplir les derrière vous et
des risques
la scène vous va y avoir la présentation
vous avez devant tout le smart les
places pour le stationnement medias
c'est pas ici au vip vous avez émis fano
citons la place enfant est pas mal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
dans les instants des croyants pour
prendre en main le mit à 2/2 à de l'alt
là c'est un petit peu la guerre il ya
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de monde on
peut récupérer pour toucher un produit
le 30 ans romain c'est un peu compliqué
néanmoins j'ai déjà on encore un peu
jeune j'ai bien couru donc je peux aller
les prendre en main et c'est vrai qu'ils
sont plutôt cool alors on va les tester
plus amplement d'ici quelques jours donc
rester connecté abonnez vous allez voir
on en reparle beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
plus
en attendant les produits comme ça a
l'air assez cool avoir effectivement ce
sont des produits milieu de gamme ont
vraiment fait une comparaison avec les
samsung galaxy à 6 pour le nier de light
et le à 8 pour le milieu d'eux on va
boire
lorsqu on va les tester si effectivement
c'est le cas à voir s'ils sont vraiment
intéressants voir ce qu'ils apportent
en attendant ce combat c'est qu'il y en
a des fiches techniques qu'ils sont
qui sont pas à rougir qui sont plutôt
pas mal on ya deux ans on a un design en
aluminium double caméra arrière 20
mégapixels 12 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de f 1.75 pas vraiment cherché
à mettre en avant
chez avis là dessus c'est vraiment de
faire des photos en faible luminosité
une caméra à l'avant également de 20
mégapixels corning gorilla glass un
snapdragon 664 ou si giga de ram dispo
en 32 64 ou 128 giga de stockage du
bluetooth 5.0 tout ça sur android one
testions tarif vous l'avez à 249 euros
sur une config en 4 gigas plus 32 gigas
de stockage 279 enquête giga + 64 giga
et 349 pour du cij igae sans le figer
garde de stockage des gants dit-il du
miel de l'actif le modèle qui forcément
moins cher néanmoins qui peut intéresser
pas mal donc je pense que là dessus et
m'ont plus viser le marché indien plutôt
que le marché français mais sakho cas
l'intéressé pas mal de monde la
différence déjà au niveau design vous
avez une petite encoche vers le haut
alors que sur le milieu d'eux vous
n'avez pas d'empocher un écran de 5,84
pouces ratio 19/9 et capteur d'empreinte
digitale au dos dispo en noirs en
couleur or ou en bleu vous avez une
double caméra arrière 12 mégapixels + 5
mégapixels reste nabringhen 625 et
surtout c'est l'autonomie qui a vraiment
retenu notre attention c'est une
batterie de 4000 oui diop erreur chez
sony annonce une autonomie jusqu'à deux
jours bien évidemment serre dépend de
notre utilisation si vous êtes très
gourmand s'évitait des choses un peu
gourmande forcément autonome il affole
chronos au soleil ça avoir également
leurs traces de test rat smartphones qui
tourne aussi sous android one etc est
disponible en 3 giga plus trop de jus et
de stockage à 170 euros 4 gigas et 64
giga de stockage à 229 euros
bien évidemment je
restez connectés pour l'instant ce n'est
qu'une prison une découverte de ces
produits on va reparler très
prochainement donc on s'abonne et on
reste connectés
en attendant ici on est plutôt pas mal
de produits de consulter un petit robot
alors ici vous avez le petit robot que
vous pouvez transformer comme ça ça et
vous avez la troisième version juste la
france est donc on va tester aussi la
prendre en main tout à l'heure normale
manche à partir avec la petite brosse à
dents pour pouvoir avoir les dents très
blanches est très très propre grâce à
shiomi là on à la brosse à dents
électrique de chiots willam électrique
tous bloch ça on va en reparler aussi
d'ici quelques temps voilà je crois si
vous êtes intéressés par les brosses à
dents ça peut être pas mal surtout ce
qui est intéressant c'est que ces chiots
me
c'est toujours une politique de tarifs
qui est vraiment intéressante alors là
vous avez la zone d'expérience avec tout
le monde tu est fondu et kg prendre et
l'autre côté vous avez le point avec mes
fans qu'ils le découvrent également
qu'ils peuvent le prendre en main alors
là vous avez tous les médias qui le
teste
comme ça nous font des vidéos pour en
parler des médias qui viennent de
partout où vous allez du média espagnol
vous avez dû mettre son doigt
là nous avons très chers collègues
d'espagne qui est en train de tester son
produit
on va aller voir maintenant il montre on
a démontré le connecter la masse fit un
africain
j'en ai déjà parlé moi de la stratos de
damas quitte là vous avez notre modèle
août et qu'on en reparlera
ultérieurement donc restez connectés là
vous avez la macif it slip également
montre connecter deux chiots me de ce
côté là un ordinateur c'est le mit
laptop air 13.3 qui est juste là for mac
est plutôt pas mal or c'est très compact
est intéressant ce petit clavier comme
ça et là les smartphones qui sont pris
en photos films et de tous les côtés des
reviews de tous les côtés dont vous
allez en trouver sur internet y en a
pour tout le monde pour toutes les
langues pour tous les goûts et pour tous
le monde à notre petit review qui est
fait ici aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu
compliqué pour faire un test en détail
pour vous montrer vraiment tous côtés
photo vidéo de ce produit donc nous
restez connecté vous inquiétez pas d'ici
quelques jours on va en parler beaucoup
beaucoup plus en détail on va le tester
directement on va voir ce qu'il vaut en
terme de photos en terme de vidéo on va
voir si vraiment les promesses qui sont
donnés par shiomi d'avoir des photos
faible luminosité
on va voir si le résultat est là on va
voir si c'est cool parce que c'est quand
même ce qu'ils font à l'espace et tout
le monde il ya du maroc
donc on va voir ça d'ici quelques jours
donc une fois de plus je vous invite à
rester connectés et la regarder on a une
jolie expo de photos il ya du monde tous
les côtés
d'ailleurs vous dites moi ce que vous en
pensez qu'est ce que vous pensez au
premier regard de ce produit est ce que
vous les trouvez plutôt intéressant est
ce que vous les trouvez décevant vous ne
marquez tout ça et comme d'hab bien sûr
on reste connectés
[Musique]
pour autant bien il ya quand même
beaucoup de sang regardez moi ces jolies
prompteur ça c'est pour les speakers
comme ça au moins ils ont leurs
antisèches n'y a pas d'erreur voilà pour
ce smartphone se mit à 2 émis à de light
j'ai pas parler trop fort parce que là
il est pas si vous voyez bien il et 1h20
du matin on l'est déjà le mercredi 25
juillet pas si vite c'était cool super
présentation de la part de chimie super
moment très très très très belle
rencontre
on a maintenant il est l'heure d'aller
se coucher merci à vous d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo je vous souhaite le meilleur
soyez sages à très bientôt mais je vous
embrasse carte
[Musique]